there have been plenty of rumors and
leaks but thanks to a live stream we
finally got an official look at the next
destiny expansion rise of iron you can
expect the typical new areas and weapons
plus the return of a fan favorite and
you won't have to wait very long to play
it rise of iron releases September 20th
rise of iron adds two new areas the
plague lands and fell winter peak
destiny starting area the wall has also
been changed the expansion also includes
a new raid new and updated strikes new
patrols and new crucible maps the
maximum white level is increasing and a
new mutated enemy faction is being
introduced as for weapons the
fan-favorite dollar horn is making a
comeback anyone can earn it by
completing a certain mission but you can
get a special black and white silver
version of the gun by pre-ordering the
expansion you can also wield the new
flaming war axe which just sounds like
one of the coolest melee weapons ever
previous destiny expansions have come to
both old and current-gen consoles but
that's not the case this time around
rise of iron is coming exclusively to
ps4 and Xbox one and it'll cost you
thirty bucks additionally some items
will be exclusive to PlayStation players
for a limited time to keep up with all
the Destiny news keep it locked at
gamespot